we have mark McGrath in studio today in
our our studio air clothes that we're
here to bury the hatchet so we're gonna
box out back we're gonna go one by one
well I might or I'll sit on your
shoulders and then will that be good
will wear a trench coat yeah we're a
trench coat you look like one will be as
tall as Mark and man good because if you
seen by my videos I like to pick on the
other small I'm glad you guys accepted
my you know my my request to fight very
angry and your friend and your fans are
very vociferous does that mean it's a
combination of feverish and vociferous I
just made it up you caught me on it yeah
you got it
I said I meant said I met Sabo Sybaris
okay what I also don't know what that
means that's yes it means like means
loud and means very practical of what
you guys do okay guys know that you guys
are out there shaking hands doing
meet-and-greets that are seven hours
long I know but and that's okay
when I know I've I'm trending on a topic
it's probably because of you do so thank
you guys okay be relevant and what I
have to be honest so someone tweeted a
clip of this like a while back of
someone bringing a sign and they you
brought them on stage yeah it was like
it was my worst nightmares like Oh bro
I'm like don't go to the show [ __ ] up
the Snowman people pay for that oh yeah
no no dude everybody has to register
where they want and like look I I want
to qualify something of that video real
quickly I reacted like a complete [ __ ]
you will never even remake an excuse for
how I reacted yeah I reacted like an
idiot I reacted like a drunken idiot
coming out of bar at 2:00 3:00 in the
morning I keep using the word reacted
yeah nothing I did I was reacting to
something that was being done to a group
of people yeah you know I was at it was
a party things like 22 almost 23 22
years ago and Madonna was having a party
yeah and this is the guys even
pre-internet I know some of your viewers
and listeners what are you talking about
there's actually time before the
internet and social media and the whole
paparazzi world was kind of brand new
TMZ didn't really exist
yeah what like what even like we're not
People magazine okay
man punch the photographer yeah it was
like that kind of thing and People
magazine and it was the internet wasn't
even a thing so I couldn't anticipate
hey you know 20 25 years later sure what
the repercussions were but coming out
that night there was a group of people
and paparazzi not not there weren't all
paparazzi but it's a group of people and
it's about 2:30 in the morning let's put
the context together yeah
and I come we're coming outside and what
paparazzi and people did back then to
get pictures was kind of harass people
kind of harangue you into reacting yeah
and I was got wow they're dropping some
f-bombs here yeah there's gay people
there and people were get a little bit
intimidated because there's kind of a
group of like you know angry guys
yelling at people gonna look over here
bah bah bah there's a paparazzi doing
this it was a group of people in
paparazzi okay now look I'm the
so-called quote-unquote kid that I
yelled at was in the bar two hours
earlier somehow this kid has become 12
years old and I was always 50 you know
he's I was never 26 and he was 22 I
every headline about the video the kid
just gets younger and younger and
younger long ago and yo mark McGrath
yells at it 14 year old and mark McGrath
last night I forgot yells at 8 you're
over eights a toddler so he just gives
that yogurt it's just so weird so I I
just feel like I should sort of speak up
on what it was and again I reacted like
a complete [ __ ]
and there's complaint plenty of good
material in there I've told you both
yeah there's tweeze my nib stirred by
the way I told that guy he'd never
making showbiz I was right about that
one and we have heard from dude since I
don't think so
yeah you know I'm saying so you know get
that what what if like there's like this
massive irony arc were like he's like
he's like mark McGrath like goes out to
become a stand-up and then just be like
a aren't you the sugar gay did they
bring signs to his show but so like I
was kind of this is kind of like you
know angry angry mob sort of mentality
it was little bit gnarly like I'm not a
tough guy but once I heard the sugar gay
comment come in I was just drunk enough
just stupid enough to react to it
yeah being the terrible fake tough guy I
am I looked at the small sky and found
him I don't know if the dude even said
it so I just react like a an EDI gold
tweezer noobs bro remember I said the
dumbest [ __ ] thing
I I'm not gonna say it's dumb I'm gonna
say it's actually gold because we have
tweezer nips for forever a good one
that's it that's a legendary and it's
pretty legendary I'm pretty proud of
that I've got it
matter of fact going into 2020 I want
all tough guys using tweezer nips it's
time I want all tough guys to tweeze
their nips thing and ask someone to
tweezer nips and there's our more
masculine thing than the tweezer drone
that I kind of worked in both contacts
you mad you're at a party sounds like
what's up bro
pulls your shirt down no no no no you
kind of gross right here you get those
things out and you just with mighty
woody and what are you gonna do dudes
way bigger than you yeah dudes way
bigger than you and you're just standing
there like an episode of scared straight
you're like yes sir I'm gonna see caress
those I was just kind of bummed out I'm
not trying to virtuous ignorning like
not just that gay thing yeah of course
I've been bullied my whole life the girl
says you know the gay thing dude I never
played that using the word gay is less
than it just well it bums me out he
always has always will I react
differently now you're not gonna bait me
into fighting you I'll bring you on
stage and go look you know I was
actually doing was standing up for
people that were intimidated that night
we're running back in the book that
being said you know I act like a
complete [ __ ] and that's kind of the
context of that video like it was at
least 21 I'm a kid anymore isn't that
man you know he was a baby diaper who's
not born yet I can't believe you throw a
baby downstairs watch CNN picked this up
25 years ago mark McGrath
took a child that threw him down the
stairs outside of a bar while saying
sugar gay
oh that's God what so people knew about
that video like before we did Harvey
alright cuz I had like it had a decent
amount of views and I'm sure like people
had written about her something before
but did we like accidentally reignite
yeah it happened every like five six
years it had it was on like
Entertainment Tonight extra the next
night because Madonna was there and I
walked her to the her car that night and
there was no romantic thing but of
course I
played it up like there was well I don't
know what happened what happened you
know I kissed her on the cheek and said
goodbye that was it but the next night
in Entertainment Tonight and extra novel
shows it said Ricky Martin out mark
McGrath Hannah's Madonna's new boyfriend
blah blah blah a video it didn't show
all the tweeze your nips moments it kind
of did the most edited entertainment
news friendly version of it but it
showed me acting like that leave [ __ ]
and every like year my mom was no longer
here would be like someone would like
put it on the internet or sit would just
get out a little bit and my mom would go
oh not again work you didn't do that
again so it follow me around forever and
right Felicia again I am never gonna
excuse the behavior I reacted I can
complete but I will always stick up my
gay brothers and sisters even if I have
to look like an idiot but again make fun
of me all day there's some great stuff
in there yeah oh yeah you guys you guys
killed it thank you who took the El I
mean was even a question who took the El
money and it was so wild when I'd come
across that video these are amount of
views and I think we had both seen it
and I was and I thought well I mean
reacting to it won't be a big deal like
I'm thinking art McGrath is just so
distant from us like there's no way he
ever sees this and when that thing
started getting traction I was like a
weak-ass top oh no you just keep it to
500,000 doesn't need to be more it's
it's it's pretty wild that the videos
you never suspect
yeah become what they cuz now like well
at our shows people will scream hey yeah
it's like one of the biggest memes like
amongst our base yeah and I know they
don't mean it in an insensitive way and
I know they know it I mean humor way but
like when you say sugar gay to someone
or to me you know it's it's it's not
offensive but it's not a bummer to me
like not really what we're still using
get like we're not homies you know I'm
saying so don't like that mean it's not
not us like on social media yeah we're
not home he's like look I've used the
word gay amongst my friends so I'm not
say have it you know but they know it's
coming from not a place of like of being
less than or making fun of sure so if
you go out there and call some guy gays
driving a truck probably to get your
head punched you know what I'm saying
depending on what what the what the
context is so you'll be happy to know
man that we
we have a lot of we've had a lot of
coming-out stories where they use sugar
gay well that wears my heart actually a
lot of cameos which are nothing good
that's how this and I'll do those all
day you know what I mean like if it's
all friendly and coming out like if I am
can if I could be sort of like any sort
of help and some all day long you know
if at some like people I love most in
this world are gay yeah you don't I mean
and I'm glad to see that that your
generation is totally cool with that so
cool that they're almost using gay in
Reverse thing meaning fun like it's
sugar gay guys a gang of like 20 year
old college girls we're going to the
sugar gay time tonight I'm like okay I
mean you know but just know what you're
kind of saying there's a little bit of
backstory there and people been bullied
you know I don't just saw them a little
darker people been really hurt by the
misuse of that name and some people are
still living in fear because of being
coming out with a sad to me yeah I
understand it because I got Lou time in
the 80s 70s dude I'm an old [ __ ]
I'm you know I remember gay was you know
it's like punk rock it was fighting
words yeah if you had blue hair in
nineteen late seventies early eighties
you're gonna get your ass beat and
there's the same situation now if you if
you you know we're gay or something yeah
so it's nice to see it evolve don't must
become a meme that's almost harmless
that's that's but it's still just no
there's a little bit of uh just be
careful where are you using yeah and
again there's a lot of material you can
throw at me and social media in there
you know there's a lot of good stuff I
forgot even half the good stuff well no
I was gonna say how to rewatch it again
when'd you see it first like when I saw
it the night he came out because I oh
you did I I have always been friends
with a paparazzi I have find it oh no
I'm in our video Oh yours yeah yeah I
was in the Big Brother house
I think cuz I was I did Celebrity Big
Brother yeah yeah honey I want to talk
about that too because I love that show
it's great job yeah and I think it
pushed that video into a little bit of
the social media sphere a little bit and
that's maybe how you guys saw it okay
I've seen a long time ago to just oh
actually that might that might be true
yeah it was just like a couple years ago
exactly I guy it was January 2018 when I
did
Celebrity Big Brother and yeah that was
yeah when we did it yeah so I was in the
house completely off the grid no little
you go in the house you're off no media
no nothing all you see his metaphor
peace losing his mind going I gotta get
out of here and Chuck Leavell about to
punch you in the face you're like oh my
god oh my god yeah L was in their memory
what he was walking around pacing like
going crazy I called bigges that's it
dude it's he's six to like in 240 and
built like a brick [ __ ] but it's
the intensity yeah yeah it looks like
you want a shark to kill somebody
yeah he's always looking like that yeah
wakes up like that and goes to sleep
like that
and he's the sweetest guy in the world
yeah but there was that on/off switch in
that dude yeah you can tell just there's
a reason why he was the champion yeah
yeah in his way class yeah so I think
when I was in the Celebrity Big Brother
completely off the grid you know people
were looking to see who these cast
members weren't totally eight nine
million views a show because it was
going against the Olympics so CBS was
really promoting it that's great you
know you look at what all the you know
all the people that were involved in Big
Brother if Mom morose that was a trip
and you they're like their paths come to
light yeah of course the sugar gay video
went one more time let's go again people
have never seen it yeah artists guys in
the internet the [ __ ] just pick it
apart I just I just I'm just glad you
guys didn't brought out the humor in it
oh yeah yeah it made me look like The
[ __ ]
that I was and am in that video for sure
but you guys did in a light-hearted way
and which was was great and if it's
smart I'm in yeah you know when I get
that blocked Instagram account from you
know Emerson soccer 20 22 and it says
sugar gay you suck or something like you
know it that then I kind of know where
it came from sure but that's when I came
out of the house my phone just exploded
what boom you know it's actually was
just mediocre enough to make it to the
finale
absolutely big brother and that's when I
saw I was at Cody Co know these dudes
what's going on it's like you know I'm
52 yes look at a newspaper delivered to
my house yeah and so it wasn't really my
way of you know Saoirse entertainment
and stuff and that's where I first
started you guys all guy when I first
saw the
now who took the owl I'm like Oh God
Jesus I gotta sit through this
[ __ ] right now and it's the
first thing I saw coming out my kids are
trying to hook me daddy we missed you
might get away I gotta see who took Elia
I'm pretty sure it's me but I want to
see it to the end and so that's when I
first noticed it and that person kind of
went down a rabbit hole but you guys
doing wow these guys are very very like
influential so first time I noticed of
um of course like no Joe Road knows guys
I've seen like popular YouTube channels
but man I saw the power of when you guys
galvanized your audience and faster and
it was interesting not that's what I
just and and you guys took a ton of the
level
you